Pulling it up on my stream. You can pull it up on your stream.
You can pull it up on your stream. No. No. Uh maybe I don't need
to I don't need to do this, okay? Hey, pull up the AI fat thing.
Is an epistemic Have you seen this? Right. Yeah, I've seen it.
Yes, I know Ryle is good at making people look fat via AI,
Right there. This is Can you Can you just be a normal human The
only good thing Ryle has ever done with AI on the Thought about
not being a complete Yeah, Ryle looks fat, dude. It's so funny.
Jesus Christ. That's up and not real. That's totally fake.
Good. I'm good. I'm good. So yeah, so if they have somebody else
who actually got sent the video within the time range, then he's
I'm mostly focused on the 2-week-old Destiny stream, actually,
not the not the recent one. Okay. You're the first credible person
I've seen acknowledging the ridiculousness of this suit. I feel
like I'm being gaslit with the way everyone is pretending there's
something damning happening here. Well, Destiny did something
wrong. That much obviously. And it would be nice if they were
able to sue him for it. I I think that like the amount of damage
that came from that is something that is uh suable for. But I
also think Pixie went about this in the worst way possible.
And What was the I mean, okay, you can have disagreements, but
like Pixie kind of got over, right? Like she Did she say why
is this affecting so
Why is this affecting I said, why is this affecting so Oh, sure.
That's Jesus. Like bro, chill. You're on camera now. I don't
think you get to say that word anymore, okay? What's Yeah, you
We're always on camera and you always said that word. Who am
I kidding? Uh we continue. I mean, Chud says it. It's just the
privilege of being British, I guess. Where are we going? Yeah,
why is Why is I mean Yeah, and basically she was she Her her
seemingly illogical approach is because she was weighing her
friendships and professional relationships with Destiny versus
an actual lawsuit against him and possibly blowing up. Like she
was planning to go work, I believe it was her and Lonerbox and
Destiny were going to do that news network thing in Miami.
That was like a whole thing, right? So she's weighing like basically
her entire future in the balance trying to figure out what she
should do. She should like let this go, how bad it is, how prevalent
it is, right? Like It wasn't an easy decision to make. And then
the Sunday videos came out and she felt like she had to act.
Yeah, not shocking. I think that even though what he did doesn't
apply under the law, yeah, I think if she had not come out publicly,
she would have had enough leverage to get him to pay. I think
she would have she would have had enough leverage to get him
to pay. A quiet [__] I love Destiny. Why can't he
just stay quiet?
Well, she came out publicly. It's like, brother, half of people
knew already. Uh that was That was already public. It was basically
like everybody who had a remote amount of knowledge was basically
sitting there like, okay. Also,
I will say she didn't go public. Other people went public and
then it was blowing up across Twitter, okay? She was not the
person who who went public first and verifiably from interviews
we have, Yuro was saying like, oh, as soon as this is public,
like obviously we're going to start posting videos about it and
stuff. Like that [__] was popping off. It would It
had been contained for as long as it could have been contained.
You're about to get BadEmpanada posting about it, too. So whether
or not she sued, whether or not she posted her posted about it.
Oh, well, he was hinting at it. Yeah, sure, sure, sure, you're
right, you're right, you're right, the Lonerbox thing. Uh he
was lying about it, but yes. Apparently he was going to do a
whole thing on it as well with like some of those DMs or something.
I haven't said anything publicly. I'm not going to say anything
publicly. You just pay X, Y, and Z amount of money and I will
never say anything about this. And yes, I think that he would
have ended up uh settling out of court. But I think that because
she by making a public statement, then yeah, that's they they
I'm not saying Destiny is an angel, but everyone involved knew
who he was and was engaging in this lewd behavior. It's horrible.
Is he reading a Oh, he is. Hold on, hold on. He is, right? Where
is angel in here? Oh, right here. Yes, okay. For a second I was
like, holy that it was I thought he was like trying to say his
own thing for a second and then he was like staring off and I'm
like, Jesus. It's not illegal. Uh it's Is Is it still illegal
conduct if uh you can hold somebody civilly liable for it? Like
is slander technically illegal conduct even though you don't
usually go to prison for it? I don't know what I don't know what
the language is. illegal. Yeah. Yeah, I just don't know if there's
like if it's I I feel like it's still illegal, but But when you
when you say illegal, people think This is civil law. It's against
civil law. They illegal, I think, right? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah,
yeah, exactly. Okay. Yeah, so then yes, illegal This is illegal
conduct. It is illegal. criminal conduct. Yeah. Well, it it's
arguably criminal, but it is I think it's testy to try to get
it to criminal through the Florida revenge porn law. Yeah. It
like that. But I By the way, uh I looked into the
the the like character evidence stuff and like introducing all
those things. Um for the federal charge where there's no intent
thing, I think probably the the prejudicial value the prejudicial
cost of introducing that evidence probably outweighs the probative
value. But for the Florida revenge tort where you need to prove
malicious intent, I think you can try you can try to construct
malicious intent through how much he was spreading it and I think
because there's no uh there's no prejudicial value to it because
you you're only trying to construct intent. Intent is one of
the major exceptions. If you're trying to use character evidence
to prove intent, it's one of the major exceptions to There's
a name for the kind of evidence. But for like character evidence.
Basically, if you're trying to introduce evidence of bad character
and it is just to prove that they're guilty of something, to
say like, well, he did it like four times before, so find him
guilty of this again. That's not allowed. But if you're trying
to say, well, he did it four times before and I'm using that
to show that he maliciously did it this time, that he has like
done it in the past, that he has humiliated women in the past,
right? I think you can do that. That is a That is a different
way of approaching it. Uh now, LitigiousGamer, if you're a lawyer
of some kind, check my logic there cuz I think that is correct.
Essentially, he has already confessed to sharing the Like the
act is already confessed to. We're not trying to prove the act,
we're trying to show evidence of intent, right? And I think you
can construct evidence of intent and I think that's why Destiny's
legal team will argue, we're allowed to actually show this stuff
because it's not a question of whether you published the the
the video. It's not a question of whether you sent the video.
legal team. What did I say? Said Destiny's legal team. Oh, sure,
Pixie's legal team will try to do that. I'm I'm fairly certain
that's the way it works. Yes, you're not showing a pattern to
convict him. You're showing a pattern to show intent. And that
is one of the major exceptions to It starts with a P. What is
it? Persistence? No. Pervasive? Pervasiveness? I have to look
up the word again. Me. Somebody help. One second. Where's Wendy?
Wendy was the one who told me the word. It is propensity evidence.
Your propensity to commit some crime. So you can't submit propensity
evidence or you shouldn't be, but but one of the exceptions for
propensity evidence is if you're trying to prove intent. And
I believe that is what they're going to argue. So I believe that
is the that is the argument he should go against and we'll see
we'll see, I guess. He did it before
the law went into effect. So like the the federal law didn't
go into effect until he until after. So it is illegal.
It just wasn't illegal at the time that he did it that we know
of. Plus on top of that, I don't think everybody did know that
he was doing stuff like this because a lot of people looked at
him as like the he's the guy who talks about consent. He talks
about how to engage in consensual actions all the time. He talks
about his interactions with other women. He has His wife, Melina,
was always coming out and talking about how good they are with
consent and how they ask for things and about things and blah
blah blah. And so I think that yeah, everybody looked at him
as like the consent guy. And then yeah, this coming out Realistically,
people probably should have looked at him as a consent violator
before this given that whole conversation with Melina. Melina
had to sit down and be like, "Listen, Destiny, you have to ask
me for permission before sending my to people. Please, stop."
Probably should have been looking at him with a little suspicion
before this. Really changes the way that people view that sort
of stuff when he talks about it, but I I I Yeah, obviously people
knew that he had like a lot of interactions, but I don't think
that's the same as him having trouble with consent like in this
scenario, but And thus there's no subject matter jurisdiction.
This argument fails outright because he sent the video to another
woman with the screen name AbbyMC in November of 2023 after the
statute's effective. Well, then Abby should be suing.
Or well, I guess okay, now. Oh, wait. Okay, yeah. No, that that
that would change things. Okay. Date. See exhibit two. Yeah,
I don't I've never heard of AbbyMC before. I looked up in AbbyMC.
So yeah, so if they have somebody else who actually got sent
the video within the time range, then he's Yeah, if that happened,
he's Wow. Well, because she's providing an affidavit to try to
um show that I will say they will need at least if she can provide
the evidence here. So in the affidavit she says that the evidence
is deleted on his end, but she has messages she she sent to other
people which she has archived. So it'll depend on what that evidence
is, but that will be enough to get to discovery. I'm almost positive.
As Tom Now, Yeah, that's like saying Rose is the one who's supposed
to sue Destiny, not Pixie. No, it's Pixie suing because it's
her video that's being shared. So there in this case, they're
saying that it's that Pixie's video was shared with this woman.
So that's what I was thinking for a second at first and I was
like, oh, wait, no, I'm wrong. That's stupid. I'm totally wrong
on that. So yeah, so it it it would still be Well, hell, did
you feel like he had an air of ownership over you because you
came up out of his community? Like did he make that known at
any point? No. No, I think he I don't think he ever acted like
he was like um like he should be running anything over on my
stream. No, I don't think so. Uh he I don't think he acted like
any different than other people who had joined up. Uh I'd say
I probably felt like I owed him a little bit coming out of his
community cuz I got favorable treatment by like some of his admins
and something and stuff, right? Like I'm sure I'm sure Queenin,
you know, you you don't cover up like crimes, but I'm sure Queenin
feels like some amount of debt to Chud and Chud's community for
like getting a little closer to the start of his streaming career,
too. Well, we we do cover up some of the crimes, though. Based.
That girl that that trans woman was actually not 17. 14 actually,
I think. That's right. I got Pixie, who's suing? The original
claim in this lawsuit happens little boys? It could Sues little
boys who like to send them their nudes. He sent things that were
deleted before
the trial started. And that in this case, they may not even need
to have they they may not even need hard evidence of this. Instead,
just her testimony that it existed. And then
that would that would change things. Cuz yeah, that would definitely
be enough to get the trial started. Like To be honest, I'm shocked
Tom has this opinion. It's my opinion. I I think I think it should
be enough if it holds up, right? But I'm pretty shocked Tom had
that opinion overall. Because I I think they'd still I think
Destiny's still saying, "Well, there's no hard evidence this
even happened, so why should you get discovery?" But it's like,
"Well, hard evidence you said it 6 months before the law came
into effect and an affidavit you sent it to somebody else like
basically a year after the law came into effect, right?" Like
that to me should be enough to get discovery. Like you did definitely
violate the law all elements of the law for like proven it before
the law came into effect. And then there's somebody testifying
that you sent it to them and deleted it after. So, I mean, to
me that should be enough to get discovery. Like We'll see. They
would definitely be going to trial at that point. Whereas my
my my statement up to this point is that they this was never
even going to make it to trial. Like never even going to make
it to trial. I was just going to be surprised if they even made
it to the evidentiary
part a portion of this, but
with something like this, this drastically
changes things. Like she can just give her witness testimony
that she got these videos. And yeah, this'll this'll end up going
to trial. And I think the second thing is I think it requires
a public publishing of the information. Um I've noticed a lot
of penny lawyers on No, not only public publishing. It's It's
not only public publishing publishing. It's publishing or sending.
But yeah, it's one of those two. So, you can either post it online
publicly to where people she knows and people that know her would
see it or it's uh just like DMing it to them. I I'm from what
I remember, it's it's
The federal statute says DMing counts. I think it's sending or
publishing. The legislature finds that a person depicted in a
sexually explicit image taken with the person's consent may retain
a reasonable expectation that the image will remain private despite
sharing the image with another person, such as an intimate partner.
It's become increasingly common practice for persons to publish
a sexually explicit image of another Oh, it's funny that it actually
hit kind of bangs down implied consent there like Destiny's argument,
right? Just because they sent you a video doesn't mean you you
can say that that video is sendable to other people. to internet
websites or to disseminate such an image through electronic means
without the depicted person's consent contrary to See, yes, or
disseminate through electronic means. So, yeah, so you can just
DM it to them. That I think that's Florida revenge porn. I think
that's Yeah, no, that is the Florida revenge porn law. Yeah,
disseminate through electronic means is the Florida state tort.
Oh, cuz yeah, they'll talk about the the malice
Which by the way, I don't think is set. It says special malice
There's like there's a weird there's a weird sort of thing going
on here where I think there's a chance you get a different standard
of malice, but I don't I don't know for 100%. I I guess like
95% chance no, 5% chance yes. That is you disseminating it through
electronic means. It doesn't have to be published publicly. It
can be privately as well. But it again would have to have So,
he he's wrong about it not meeting two parts of this. It only
doesn't meet one part, which is the intent to harm. Could lead
to its further dissemination to others. Yeah, and this is like
I mean, he said just a minute ago that there's people like making
arguments about like, "Well, technically he published it by sending
it through DMs." I've seen even worse arguments than that as
I brought up earlier where people Well, technically they couldn't
have published them without him sending it in the first place.
Like that doesn't matter, dude. That just doesn't matter. It's
like it's just totally It absolutely matters. So, there's a classic
but but for Well, it's a classic but for declarations how a lot
of laws work. It's like like how you determine causality is basically
you can you can roll back in the chain. Now, if it was like if
he'd done something that wasn't illegal, that wasn't violating
anything, that was like a totally neutral act, um and then it
set off that chain, you can't be held responsible in that way.
But when you are doing something criminal, it's like you are
a part of that causal chain, you can't be held responsible. What
were you going to say though? Sorry, I cut you off about damages.
Well, I mean, yeah, it'd be it'd be relevant to damages, right?
Surely you could if if there's a but for, you can determine that
well, you sent it to these people and it caused this much damage
and you are on the hook for the damage caused even though it
was a secondary action, if you know what I mean. Yeah, I don't
know so, it'll depend on what happens precisely, but it will
he could be I I don't know exactly how that'll go. I think probably
like obviously he would be more on the hook for damages if he'd
published all of this stuff, but then Yeah. Yeah. it it will
come down to like Okay, well, if you if you published it twice
that we know of, right? Then how many times did you publish it?
I wonder if like if they find, you know, a bucket of videos of
people or something, right? That have access that have access
laws with like a bunch of people accessing this from different
places like, "Oh, probably we can hold you responsible for more."
It'll depend. The but for declaration I don't think is I think
it's basically if if you have a but for that shows you are a
part of that chain, I think you can be held liable. But you you
I think probably if you're depending on how foreseeable the the
publishing is, which for Destiny you'd argue, right? He says,
"Oh, if you like DM stuff to enough people. If you're in a if
you're in a group chat with like five people, that's basically
public. It's not public. he understands like privacy on the internet.
Sorry, but for but for Destiny sending Pixie's video to somebody,
it would never been published widespread on the internet. So,
there is there's no Basically, Destiny has a pivotal a a core
action that without that action, the following chain of events
could never have unfolded. They're not relevant. It doesn't He
still doesn't meet the rest of those the rest of those aspects
where he has to have done it maliciously.
And there's just no evidence for that. Like it seems like he's
just being a Like that's it. That's not malicious. That's not
him trying to harm somebody. I think the intent there is pretty
clear. He's just trying to get off. Like that's that's that.
So, yeah, the the But yeah, It's not. He's just a gooner. Totally
wasn't some deranged malicious psychological power play. Yeah,
so never be that. Yeah, like I think the argument will be Pixie
has many DMs where, you know, Pixie's like sent you messages
basically being like, "Hey, it'd be horrifying to me if my [__]
ever got out. Hey, I don't want this discussed with anybody.
Hey, this would be really really bad if like Right, she obviously
has all the way along shown how horrified she'd be if this was
ever shared with people or if it was ever known. And having those
conversations, does that change does that color your action to
go and like share this around to multiple people including I
don't know how you make this declaration where like I think the
first thing he said when he saw the ABMC thing drop was he went
to his public chat and he said, "Well, she's just insane and
unhinged."
It's like, "Okay, so how
how are you confident that sharing a video of Pixie with her
wasn't going to be shared publicly anywhere if that was your
opinion?" I don't know. I don't know, man. You don't have consent,
it's malicious to share it. Um this is beyond that. Um the Florida
revenge porn law has a very specific intent. So, we can keep
going, but hold on. It's cyber harassment. I can I can go into
I can read it to you guys. It's like it's a very specific intent
they'll have to try to construct and I think probably it's very
difficult. Malicious.
Person who willfully and maliciously cyber harasses another person.
So, for this there's malice, but there's another malice standard.
There's like two. God, I It's somewhere else. There's like another
piece to this where maliciously
it's like with intent to actually psychologically harm or something
like that. So, like basically I'm sharing it with this person
with the intent of like actually with that person. Like in this
moment I have formed the intent Pixie send the video. And I think
that's probably not something you can do, but I think to construct
that intent, they're going to say, "Hey, Pixie, you had this
conversation and you didn't just send this once in like a moment,
you sent it many times over time, right?" That's what they're
trying to say. Like you have a you have a like what do you call
it? Like an intent to basically like violate these people's privacy
to to to make them upset. And now that is that is difficult.
I don't know if it'll work. I In fact, I would bet against it
working, but I they'll make that legal argument. And depending
on what they find, if they find a whole bunch of other instances
of Destiny like sending [__] you could probably make
that argument, right? Hey, if you if all the only conversations
you ever had with this person involved like how private they'd
like to keep things or if every conversation includes a privacy
talk, then if you've violated that privacy multiple times, it
seems like you are doing something more intentional than not
there. Why else is he so scared to share his Discord DMs? I mean,
that's just not an American argument, Rile. American argument
is privacy first. You need you need a reason to look at those
DMs. He did say he would keep himself if they got a subpoena
for his DMs though, which is very funny. I keep saying to these
people who are like trying to cope their ways. Please,
do not go back on that promise. Please, Destiny. Okay, if you
hear me if you hear me if you're watching this stream right now,
please hold to your word. Okay, please for the love of God. And
to him being legally responsible for this when it's just blatantly
clear he's not. It's just blatantly clear he's not. But yeah,
because she didn't publish it and it was solo. Now that argument
just goes right out the window. There's no way to hold him responsible
for this. I think it's pretty obvious why this argument is incredibly
stupid. Oh, that's right. That's right. That's right. So the
criminal thing was where the person was saying he meets all of
the requirements of the law. That's all that matters. And I was
like, "No, that's not all that matters because there's no damages
attached. You have to have damages. When you sue somebody, you
have to have damages. So in a like even if Destiny met So here
you could say, "How is this?" Basically, somebody's going to
rob your house. Your cousin has a spare key to your house. Your
cousin basically, in exchange for some favor, trades the key
to a robber. They rob your house. How culpable is your cousin
for that person robbing your house? Like what damages does your
cousin owe? The argument that there are no damage damages there
that they they could owe that they had no idea what what could
happen like giving that key away. I think that's pretty insane.
I guess maybe they traded away without knowing the person was
going to violate or go to your house and rob you. It's like something
like that. There's like some there's some hypothetical we could
construct here. I it's just not you you don't have like low or
no culpability there. I think the malice thing is the the thing
that they're going to get stuck on here for charge two. This
is cyber stalking. all the requirements of this law, there's
still no damages attached to his actions. There's only Oh, true.
They are suing for punitive damages too, which includes psychological
damage, which I you can absolutely hold them culpable for. only
damages attached to Solo's actions. And so Solo is the only person
who can be sued. In a criminal case, all you have to do is just
meet the minimum requirements. That's it. Whereas here, you only
have to meet the minimum requirements to go to trial. But at
trial, then you get to like argue what your damages are and all
this other stuff. And there's just no way to attach damages to
anything that Destiny did in this case. So there's no way that
this would make sense. But in a criminal case, Does Tom think
that you have to form like an intent to be responsible for damages?
I feel like there are lots of cases where negligence can lead
to you being held responsible for damages, right? I feel like
that's that's got to be there's no way you have to actually form
like a specific So for the law, there's an intent requirement.
But if there wasn't an intent requirement, and I'm not sure for
some of the other ones where there is, I feel like he's he's
talking about because Destiny didn't intend to do this, that
you can't charge him damages. And that's just not true. He's
Yeah, you don't have to do that. You don't have to argue damages.
You just have to argue that they did the thing and that's that.
And so yeah, a lot of people are like, "No, all he did was you
know, all he has to do is just meet the minimum requirements
of the law and then he's going to lose." And it's like, "Nah,
that's that's just enough for them to go to court only." No,
I believe there are statutory damages attached to the federal
statute as well. That's not That's how criminal cases work is
you like you just meet the minimum requirements of the law, you're
going to go to jail or you're going to get convicted. Whereas
in this one, that's just enough to go to court. There's no way
you win a case where you have no damages. You can win a lawsuit
with no damages
and yet
still end up Yeah, still there's it just can't it can't happen
because the damages are all attached to somebody else's actions.
So Yeah. But in this
Is it the single private transmission of a video to one individual
does not rise to the level of extreme conduct. But it was clearly
not just one transmission. Clearly, because of the Twilight Hour
affidavit they brought in, okay? In the response to the response
for the preliminary injunction request, who was never part of
the original complaint or any amended complaint or Yeah, but
the problem is that in the original complaint Sorry, in his response
to the original complaint, he says he's never sent it to anyone
else. There are no other parties that can possibly come forward
saying that he sent Pixie's videos to them. He did say that.
She has stated this numerous times, including in his response,
is that there is no way another party could come forward saying
that he sent those videos because he didn't do it. I still have
a I dude, I need lawtubers to get on this cuz I need some other
people to go and look through this and say, "Hey, is this perjury
or not?" I need to know. How can you argue against Tom? He clearly
has criminal experience and that's why he knows. True. Extreme
Dad throwback. Nice. Thank you, Xbox. party has come forward
Bro, Extreme Dad in here was like trying to argue his lived experience
was why he knows about the law and [__] It was [__]
crazy. saying that he sent them those videos. That That That's
That's bad. Like that this is really bad for him. Like this is
really bad for him cuz yes, this is this changes everything.
If somebody's now claiming that they were sent the videos within
the timeline. Yeah, I'm glad I watched this cuz yeah, this this
definitely changes things. This This changes everything. Don't
you think the whole docket This is like, you know, people being
in a room and someone saying like, "Yeah, they slipped poison
into their cup when the other person walked away." And
and then they drank it and Thank you for the 16 months. Let's
go, buddy. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. died. And he's like,
"Where's the evidence that I did that? Where's the evidence?
Like come on. Show some like show a video of me doing that. Like
give me a break." It's like, "In this case, like you kind of
having just the statements in and of themselves, that is that
is about as much as we would expect. lie for years, which is
why Solo Tiny Leaks was able to access them, and which is the
reason that the video and other content was substantially certain
to have become one of public knowledge, which Oh.
Oh ho ho. That's how he got it. Okay. So he sent it through Google
Drives.
And then And then the link he was able to just get a handle on
the link. That is something I did not know. Okay. Hold on. I
need to go back. Sorry, I was sending a DM there for a second.
I need to see what he thinks changes things Let me rewatch this.
I will say with regards to the Pixie case, the Google Drive stuff
is relevant possibly now. It seems like Abby said she received
it through a Google Drive link. I don't know that in the previous
Pixie stuff before that we had any evidence of the Google Drive
stuff. It was just that we knew he had sent other people's videos
through Google Drive. The Pixie one seemed to be embedded through
Discord. Don't you think the whole docket This is like, you know,
people being in a room and someone saying like, "Yeah, they slipped
poison into their cup when the other person walked away." And
and then they drank it and died. And he's like, "Where's the
evidence that I did that? Where's the evidence? Like come on.
Show some like show a video of me doing that. Like give me a
break." It's like, "In this case, like you kind of having just
the statements in and of themselves, that is that is about as
much as we would expect. Tom's actually not doing terrible. lie
for years, which is why Solo Tiny Leaks was able to access them,
and which is the reason that the video and other content was
substantially certain to have become one of public knowledge,
which Oh.
Oh ho ho. That's how he got it. Okay. So he sent it through Google
Drives.
That's not how Solo got the Pixie video, I'm almost positive.
I don't I Maybe, but I I thought from the transcript it didn't
look like that. And then And then the link he was able to just
get a handle on the link. That is something I did not know. Okay.
Which alone defeats defendant's assertions regarding the merits
of this claim. So again, I will say that these arguments are
very provoke any damages done by those things.
I don't I have no unless they're claiming that I also own those
websites, but okay, I don't understand. Defendant's empty. Yeah,
this is this is insane. This is But this is what they've done
the entire time. From the very beginning, they're claiming that
he's responsible for other people's actions.
And that's just not That's just not the way that this works.
That's [__] insane. and self-serving assertion In
They continue to repeat this claim even though it's like patently
false if you just read Hannah Brooks' declaration. Uh so but
they just like to lie over there. See Hannah Brooks' declaration.
It's different. Where we got I guess, so based I guess. So this
isn't the Abby thing. Okay, I missed it. Okay, so the So his
Destiny's thing, okay? When he says you should go look at the
video of me eating if you want to see I saw on Kiwi Farms or
something. When he points people to those videos, okay? He's
somehow I don't know if DGGers just have no brain cells, they've
never looked at anything outside of the Destiny lens, but they
somehow ignore the fact that these are in fact in the same post,
right? Like there's literally no reason to think, "Oh, I'm posting
I'm pointing you to video 30 of 45 in that post, okay? But not
any of the other videos in there. Nope. Nope. Nope. There isn't
any denial of the Abby thing then, right? So far, we have not
heard a denial of the Abby thing. Okay, so let me keep skipping
forward then. He never explicitly denies the Abby thing, but
he does say she's lying. And the one where they talk about the
fact that somebody else came forward, something MC, and that
that person has a claim that So, so one of the bigger deals is
that the There's the Ford statute and the federal statute. And
in the federal statute, the reason that this one doesn't apply
is because the the date that they're making a claim for is before
the statute went into effect. And so, it can't apply. But now,
in this one from 7 days ago, this
somebody else comes forward and says, "No, he also sent the video
to me." In that one, he has I have not heard any denial of that,
and they are And in that one, they're What do you call it? In
that one, it would be within the within the timeline to where
it would actually apply. So, now it sounds like Bro, who said
time is fungible? Oh, Nick said that. Me. God, that was triggering.
do have him sending the video of Pixie to somebody after the
date. What is Cardi? I don't want to be harmed. Two blank days.
Each of these assertions What is Cardi? I don't know. Yeah, so
I'm sure he said I don't know what it means. person. And so,
that is all we we've heard is that she doesn't have any evidence
that he did this. But again, in this case, really all she needs
to give is witness testimony that she was sent the video. That's
it. And she has signed an affidavit making this claim. So, this
one is Yeah, this this the federal one seems to be legit now.
The declaration of Abby was to keep the name of the person out
of direct hands of us so that the Yeah, so Okay, so now he is
finally responding to that part. So, that's the Abby MC part
that we were saying. So, yeah, he So, he he is saying that he
thinks she's lying now cuz yeah, it was weird that he didn't
say anything yesterday about this when or in the not yesterday,
but in the other video that we were watching, when that is like
the thing that's going to [__] him now. Like that
is like the major thing. It's weird how he didn't talk very much
about it. That will totally [__] him. It's true.
The person could Uh Destiny said that they haven't given any
evidence that they have tried removing this, but this says otherwise.
Uh that's true, Saibah. That is true. This says that they do
have the subpoenas, and they do know that they tried getting
it removed. Does any MPD Dude, why is Tom watching me? that they
tried getting it removed. Hey, why is Tom watching me? The [__]
Hello? Why is this guy watching me? I don't know this guy watched
me. The [__] He reviews you for a bit. Did he disagree
with anything I said? I think I was I I think I've been very
fair in like my legal analysis overall. Everything. Actually,
cuz I I literally listened to him just now and I'm like, "Oh,
I think he I I think he like kind of hit all my points." That's
weird. Okay. Yeah, I don't know what else we got here. Oh, little
little tweet. Hold on. What's this? Tom [__] can't
get enough of this
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. It's Why you got to make him look cool? I'm
Oh, man. AI is too powerful. That's not AI. It's literally just
That's literally just audio audio editing. We could do that 20
years ago, by the way. Ain't no AI there. Okay, I got it, Ryle.
I got it. I got it. This is him reviewing my Is this muted or
something? Not saying anything. Yeah, I feel like we have to
at least go through that
Is that that motion even though or the the affidavit because
yeah, he I don't think Destiny went over the actual affidavit
and what their claim is. So, the Excuse me, and we don't So,
basically, it's these ones that they want unredacted copies of
these. I believe they argue for unredacted copies of these filed,
but I didn't do a deep read-through of these things. So, we'll
we'll see exactly what they say. So, the reasoning for this is
plaintiff plaintiff Pixie Pixie's legal team failed to meet and
confer prior to filing her motion. Plaintiff refuses to identify
the name Plaintiff relies team should do is they should talk
regardless of how it was filed redacted. Dude, I can't imagine,
dude. I get so antsy when I literally just listen to other people
read stuff sometimes.
Like I'm sorry, I just I don't want to I don't want to react
to other people reading things most of the time. It makes me
just feel weird. Dude or not, right? It's a little concerning,
I would say. But anyway, at 7:59 p.m. EDT on Friday, May 2nd,
2025, plaintiff's counsel emailed the undersigned stating, "Pursuant
to local rule 7.1, we are meeting and conferring on the following
motions: Motion to file under seal certain documents and and
its proposed order, motion for leave to exceed page limit on
reply memorandum." The documents to be filed under seal are certain
statements by witnesses, which purpose is to keep which Whose
purpose? Which purpose? I Whose purpose, right? I don't know
how you'd say this in in plural. Which purpose is to keep their
names out of the public. You and your client will know their
identities. I apologize for not reaching out before. It's been
an intense week. Okay, so they're I feel like I shouldn't have
to give more commentary on a video where Tom's just silently
listening to me than Tom gives on my video, right? I should just
be able to watch this. Basically saying, "Hey, we're we're filing
these things." says the audiobook guy, but I'm not giving commentary
on an audiobook. It's different giving commentary here. The way
I see this is they're saying, "Okay, we don't know exactly how
this is going to work. We're filing it redacted because we don't
want the identities to be exposed publicly, and now we're meeting
in conference to discuss the
way we're going to pursue this, okay? Hey, the way this actually
works with 7.1 is because there's a timeline because there's
a time limit on responding, they filed the motion to seal first,
okay? Then, based on that motion to seal, they filed the document
they filed the affidavits, which are argued for under that motion
to seal. And because if there is a time limit, you basically
would have to file these to be with the court, they filed the
documents redacted publicly, right? And then they're going to
wait for the judge to say whether the motion to seal applies
or not. Now, I don't know if those become unfiled or what if
the judge says, "No, actually, you can't. These can't be filed
under seal." I actually don't know what happens. That's literally
That's literally why I was like, "No, I don't think so. I don't
think so. I don't I don't think so." But that's I don't know.
I understand So, Destiny's problem there is basically like, "Well,
if these can't be filed under seal." Here's the thing, if if
they're allowed to be filed under seal, then I think those names
could be shared with Destiny, right? They would be shared with
Destiny. That's the that's the plaintiff argument. That's the
Pixie's counsel's argument. Like if these are going to be filed,
we'll give you the names. And if these aren't going to be filed,
if these are going to be allowed to go through, then we're we're
just going to say like we don't want anything shown here because
these people don't want to testify unless it's under seal. But
I think I think the the argument they're making is we'll give
you the identities once it's confirmed that these things will
be under seal. Right? I'm pretty confident. We play blame it
on Hassan. I do miss that song. Uh supplementary Brettler declaration
A emphasis added at 11:40 p.m. on May 2nd, plaintiff Again, at
least two to three people Destiny 100% knows. Like Destiny would
I believe literally have bought plane tickets for these people
around the timings that are like explicitly declared in in the
affidavits. Like he should have a literal paper trail of the
names he
I don't know what he's arguing here exactly. He's like making
a very disingenuous argument. I don't know what it is. Before
Before Abby's affidavit was even filed with the court, in fact,
he was checking in with West and Darius about Abby himself. That's
how much he knew this person, knew who this person was. Filed
her motion for leave to file declarations under seal, ECF number
48,
at 12:05 a.m. EDT on Saturday, May 3rd, after the deadline to
file her reply papers, plaintiff filed the declarations in redacted
form at 10 to actually see on May 3rd. Yeah, it looks like I
would have to buy these in order to actually see.
Oh, he's looking up how to get onto CourtListener. I see. It's
CourtListener. He knew he was screwed if Abby got involved. I
think also that's why Like if I were Abby, I I try not to give
advice to people, okay? I just I'm People have to make their
own decisions, and you just let them be. I don't like Destiny
or Darius or whoever the [__] okay? There's By the
way, Darius leaked all of his DMs with Abby from Abby like trying
to talk to him before she got on his stream the other night.
Bizarre [__] I can only assume this is in like an
effort to discredit her. It seems like nothing's there that like
actually discredits the testimony. So, I don't know. We'll see,
I guess. We'll cover that all tomorrow. Little teasers, I guess.
Um Uh Israel good, Palestine Palestine good, Israel bad, or whatever,
okay? It's that thing again. She did it Wow. I'm not pulling
it up on my stream. You can pull it up on your stream. You can
pull it up on your stream. No. No. Right, maybe Ryle's got an
issue, okay? I I don't need to I don't need to do this, okay?
You're coward. Longhouse We don't mock our plus-sized ladies
here, okay? We don't mock them at all. We leave them alone. Wait,
pull up the AI fat thing. Is an epistemic Have you seen this?
Ryle Yeah, I'VE SEEN IT. YES, I know Ryle is good at making people
look fat via AI, okay? I doubt that. This is Can you Can you
just be a normal human being? Can you not be a complete prick
for like 2 seconds? The only good thing Ryle has ever done with
AI other than not being a complete
for like 2 seconds.
My hair doesn't look fat, dude. It's so funny.
Is it on his Twitter? I don't even know where it is. It's on
his Twitter. Wait, it's so good. What? No. I don't know what
this post is. Something else. Okay.
Jesus Christ. That's up and not real. That's totally fake. I
don't know why somebody would make this. It's actually so disturbing.
That's so funny. Dude, do you think you could have enjoyed in
this like body this small for a woman if you did that? Yes. Yes,
absolutely you could. It's so [__] up, dude. It's
Oh my god, perfect for tomorrow. Thank you, Top Bronson. Yes.
We got Top Bronson made a couple of their emotes, by the way.
Like this one. That one will be funny. Okay. All right. All right,
what is this? Officially outed it Not so air tight. Officially
outed as a fraud. Destiny and Orbit taking massive L's left and
right. Okay. a logical
theory that can attempt to solve this. But it doesn't. Agrippa's
trilemma posits that any attempt to justify belief leads to an
infinite regress, dogmatism, or circularity.
Coherentism is an epistemological theory that can that can attempt
to solve this. Okay. Well, you say that, but you got evidence
that you're not aware of the basics. So, we're not going to listen
to anything you say about philosophy when you can't name one
book from Plato or the universe. Can you name one book from Plato
or the universe? But no, I can't. Cuz you haven't read it. Just
admit that you haven't read it. I have read it. But you don't
know any titles of the most the most famous philosophical texts
in
You're a suit. I'm not a suit. I've read name one of them. Nope,
but I Because you haven't read because you haven't read them.
Again, this is not But you don't know any I'm pulling it back
cuz I was looking at the in chat here. I have to watch Jade Ior
apparently in Google.
Can you name one book from Plato?
You can't. Cuz you haven't read it. Just admit that you haven't
read it. I have read it. But you don't know any titles of the
most famous the most famous philosophical texts in history.
You're a suit. I'm not a suit. I've read them. But you can't
name one of them. Nope, but I Wait. Hold on. It's totally fine
if she says she hasn't read them. She doesn't know about them.
I don't know why you say you've read them, but you don't know
names. Yeah.
I Cuz I Like I remember Wicked Supreme like kind of embarrassed
Sunday in like a in an argument like this where Sunday was trying
to like get names of books out of him and Sunday hadn't read
them. I don't know why you'd say you've read them. Because you
haven't read them.
Again, this is not the dunk. Your ideas are not worthwhile because
you're a suit. At least I'm not lying about having a degree in
philosophy, I guess. Cuz if you did, you could definitely tell
us the difference between absolutism and What? I gave you that
I gave you that explanation of the difference. You said they're
synonymous. In the context, in terms of intentionality, how I'm
using it, they can be synonymous. Do you know that words have
can be The word What a weasel answer. That's crazy. The word
kid, can it mean two different things? Uh Oh, so your answer
to what's the difference between absolutism and objectivism is
equivocating. That's amazing. Honestly. kid mean two different
things? Power level. You have the highest kid mean two different
things? Uh yeah, of course. Okay. So, words
are de So, here's the thing. I don't know what philosoph philosophy
very well. I don't know exactly what's going on here. I suspect
we could be running into another um whistleblower kind of incident.
I That's what we were saying earlier. I suspect in the under
context. Yeah, so you're answering the definition here by equivocating.
meaning of the words. You don't know what equivocation is. That's
the false meaning of the words.
Oh. I don't know what she's saying, but I think she's winning
right now. Just judging by the body language. So, he's acting
like absolutism when we're talking about it as a definition,
it's just his personal definition that he's thinking of in the
moment. When I'm asking about the school of absolutism versus
the school of objectivism,
I'm not talking about that. I'm talking about your That's what
I am asking you
because I was critiquing your argument.
Good one. Good one, Jay. Yeah. So, all the yapping wasn't addressing
the critique. Again, if you just want to deal with the terms
But you've never read Plato even though you claim you've read
all five Plato books you said you've read, and you can't name
one. Because you lied.
So, you At least I know the difference between these two two
There's I So again, I guess you'd have to go back to the argument.
There's no way you read five books from an author you can't name
a book from that author. That's like a completely preposterous
statement, right? I I think we could easily say that. I think
generally like I I don't know the idea that you can't you you
read any author's books you can't like at least be like, "Oh,
it's the one about Yeah. Yeah. Something that deals with. Like
you can you can do something that you can Describe some transcription
of like a pack passage. Like yeah, you could say, "Oh, I remember
like this quote from the book that was like really This was the
Yeah. Yeah, and you and you can like try and make some attempt
to remember it, but no, she's just like, "No, I don't remember
names. I don't remember names." So, you lied. You're admitting
you lied.
You didn't lie. Nope. But you can't name one of the five. Nope.
The most famous philosophical text in history, Plato's dialogues.
Mhm. And when I read through it in school, it comes in the five
dialogues. So, I didn't memorize the specific books within each
of And you can't name one of them. Uh of the five dialogues,
nope. But can you Right. Because you don't know the topics that
you're talking about. Because you can't You don't understand
what you're talking about. You're a suit. Plato, Kant, you don't
see the difference there? Name one Name one book of Kant. Do
you need to help you? It starts with a C. One of the Kant books
that's famous starts with a C.
I don't know it. Right. Because you haven't read it. You said
I read three Kant books. Describe stuff. I Dude, I All these
books I just can't remember the names of. All these books I just
can't remember the names of. That's rough. Cuz you haven't read
it. Just admit you haven't read it. I have read it. Just be
This is just like basically proving that you are a suit. You
are a fraud. Just like live like this. This guy is a not Wait,
is Jay Dyer actually I just kind of assumed he was like he'd
had some He debates people. He's not actually right. There are
people who find him compelling, right? He came up Well, there
must be people who find him compelling. I only just found that
by him saying pretty even Tone Perardite in some of the stuff
I watched, but maybe he's smart in other places. Maybe he was
just He just seemed drunk when I saw him. Okay. Okay. I I feel
like there's no way he's like totally but maybe You haven't.
Because they're famous, anybody in this domain would know. You
admitted this. You remember the book that You remember the book
that you read recently and its title? Uh eventually I did. Yeah.
But you can't remember the most famous texts in philosophy.
In future debates, I'll do my best to memorize book names. Do
you want to deal with my ideas yet, or do you just want to keep
on being bad faith to try to get out of this? One philosophy
book from any of the philosophers. Uh one philosophy book, uh
Plato's Republic. Okay. Did you read that? Uh no, I actually
didn't. Wait. Why didn't she just say Plato's Republic when he
was asking for a Plato book name? Because it was one that she
read. The name of one she read. Well, also he also said Plato's
Republic, right? I think he said it. I feel like he said it,
but maybe Oh, no, he said the other one. What was the the one
that came in five books? Can you name one you've read? Uh off
the I don't know. By the way, I don't represent that I've read
any of these books or know anything about these ideas. So, He's
asking for one of the five dialogues. Okay, I see. Top of my
dome, not right now. Cuz you haven't read the subject matter,
and you can't debate Uh Oh, Nietzsche's What's it called? Uh
trying to remember.
Uh the
I mean, if I can list Do you want me to list what's within the
books? Okay. The genealogy genealogy of I'm going to help
Thus spoke I'm going to help you. That's not the book that I
read. That's not the one I'm citing. That spoke there there is
not the book that I'm talking I'm giving you the first words
of Nietzsche books. The Anti I don't know why you think this
is a dunk.
Because you don't know any of the subjects that you're Oh, thesis,
right? Antithesis is like his thesis antithesis, right? Right?
Do you want to engage with the ideas that I don't know philosophy.
You called into question my degree, and you can't name a single
philosophy book. I'm not claiming to have a degree in philosophy.
said I was a fraud. I think you're a fraud because you can't
you don't know the difference between absolutism
which you absolutely The book The book's literally called Anti-Oedipus.
[__] I my best. But I've already I've already said
I don't know. So, That's the WHY WHY WOULDN'T SHE JUST SET HERSELF
free and say she doesn't know? That's so much easier. I Dude,
I don't know. I I don't know. tropical book, you idiot.
I already No, you didn't. You can't name one. I just did. You've
read None. I've read parts of Thus Spoke Zarathustra. Does that
count for Cuz I helped you with the title. Again, I can go through
like the book that I'm thinking of of Nietzsche and like what
it is. This just isn't the dunk you think it is. And what's the
philosophy As a pro debater, you should be able to engage with
ideas and not have In Thus Spoke Zarathustra, what's he lay out?
Um
I can't remember all of it. I already said that I only read parts
of it. What view of history What? What view of history does he
lay out in Thus Because you haven't read it. You're a liar. I
I said I That's like Nobody It's not as punchy, so nobody will
like
care about that as much, but that is like a way better point
right there where he's like asking actually like critical questions
about the content of the book, and she can't answer those. Then
it's like, "Okay, then what are we Because you're a liar. Bro,
you're so know the basics of the book. You don't know the basics.
Again, I don't remember the titles of any of these books. If
you'd like to engage with the ideas that we're talking about,
I'd love to do that. Can you define yet the difference between
absolutism and objectivism? Just once. That Thus Spoke Thus Spoke
Zarathustra talks about. This is just not the optic dunk you
think it is. Again, You You don't have no knowledge of philosophy
at all. I don't remember what they're called. You don't know
anything because you didn't read them. I read I think I think
I've read
40-ish chapters of Bertrand Russell Bertrand Russell, I think
it's called Introduction to Western Philosophy, right? I think
I read like 40 chapters. I wanted to kill myself the whole time.
It is the driest, most garbage read I've done in my life. I think
it's Introduction to Western Philosophy. It was horrible.
Top 12 takeaways, it just talked about like Greek philosophers
and stuff. Oh, the the one interesting concept that like obviously
is intuitive that I that I do remember from the first part of
the book is he talks about the shift of people realizing that
like city-states are way weaker than nations because city-states
inherently can't have enough people to defend themselves against
nations, but they can have they can contain like a wealth. And
so there's this this
What would you call it? There's just the idea that like basically
you should only ever collect as much wealth as you're able to
defend. But that then nations started to overtake city-states
after a while because nations could just muster like a whole
bunch of people, run them at the city-state, steal all their
wealth. So that's that's part of that book, okay? Boom, there
I did it. I read that book like I'm not joking like at least
a decade ago. failing because you lied. I'm not failing. You're a
liar. I'm really mad cuz I this time like compared to You said
that I'm a fraud. and you're so mad about it's the sleep. I didn't
get sleep. I can't remember things. Yeah, I flew back from Israel
and was up for 30 hours straight.
Oh, hold on. I might have gotten that book name way wrong. Is
that not Bertrand Russell? Oh, no, it is. Well, there is a copy
from Bertrand Russell. A history A history of Western philosophy.
Whoops. And then flew here.
I don't know what book No, I These aren't books that I've read.
But you're going to call me out as Well, you don't know the difference
between absolutism and objectivism. You're going to call me out
as a fraud. These are pretty basic things in philosophy and I
would hope that you would know it. You failed. Exciting books
doesn't mean that you're educated in philosophy. that you don't
know anything about it. of people who read books all the psychological
literature Brian does with the sound board is awesome. I don't
know what I don't know what it's adding to
The difference
Well, you don't know the difference between absolutism You failed.
Exciting books doesn't mean that you're educated in philosophy.
that you don't know anything about it. There's lots of people
Oh, sorry. No, she said
You lied.
I don't know how long you want to keep
No, I did not admit that. I have not lied. I couldn't name one
book or the subject matter of the said I've I feel like if I
were this guy, I would stop harping on this and I'd just say
that it's like far more embarrassing to say that you read these
books, you can't really describe the ideas, and you don't know
the names. Like you've Like what is the point of reading books?
Like you've actually just
instead of just like not knowing something, you've actually attempted
to learn it and totally failed to retain any relevant information.
That's far more embarrassing. one book that's a that's a philosophy
book. After I helped you I already said that I didn't read even
Plato's Republic. What is the speak there so I already said I
don't remember the part specifically. I remember cracking the
and you're going to call me out as a fraud. That's not true at
all. I don't know why you need to do that. Like I wouldn't be
shocked if Erudite just picked this up through like debating
and Discords, right? And then Wikipedia-ing like various topics.
I think that's how I know most philosophy terms. But I don't
think that's like embarrassing. I don't think you have to be
like, "Oh, I Why don't you just just say that and just Just don't
claim you read books.
Yeah, just don't claim you read books. Like look, I I haven't
read the book. Are you going to argue with me or are you just
going to cry about the fact that I haven't read the book? Like
that that's what you do and then you you move on. But no, she's
refuses to do that. She's going, "Oh, I've read the books. I've
read the books. Can we move on? I've read the books. Can we move
on?" It's like "What are you doing right now?" Uh I don't know.
Crazy. I have no knowledge of the losing this debate to this
stupid woman that I keep interrupting. SO I DON'T KNOW. ALL THESE
BOOK titles
She's She's freaking out. She's freaking out. How old are you
again? Like 40 or something? I have no knowledge of the subject
matter. Aren't you like 40? Yeah. That's again Okay, okay. Now
Now I'm sorry. Now you deserve it. Now you deserve it.
I'm sorry. Now you deserve it. If you're going to talk about
ages, now you actually deserve it. Wait, play it
I I'm sorry. What are you doing talking about ages with other
people? What are you doing? Actual age, sure. Actual age. What?
What is she doing? I don't remember the exact Somebody could
link me the exact thing, but Jesus. insane. Oh, hold on. There's
apparently a worse clip here. Is this the whole thing around
you watching Tiger Woods all the time? Name Name one of Kant's
books. Knowing books is what we do. of his What Name one writing.
That would be Wait, wait, hold on. That might be simple. Just
one. I've already told you I don't know the title of any of these
things. I don't even know the title of William Castellos' articles
that I'm citing. I have no idea. I don't memorize titles of things.
read any of Kant's books? I did. I read one of them. You said
three earlier. Now which which one? I don't remember. three or
one? I think I read one. But you said three earlier. Maybe I
was wrong. Maybe I You lied. No. You just lie about
God dammit. Sorry, I was doing something on the other tab.
I don't memorize titles of Did you read any of Kant's books?
I did. I read one of them. You said three earlier. Now which
which one? I don't remember. three or one? I think I read one.
But you said three earlier. Maybe I She did say three earlier.
That's in the previous clip we watched. Maybe I Or you lied.
No. You just lie about what you think you know because you're
on a performative debate setting I and you totally failed. Which
is crazy because you'd think that if I was such a liar and such
a stupid head, you could just answer my questions. So got shown
up that you don't You
don't know the difference between
You don't know the difference between these words.
You don't understand the context of these for me is not knowing
titles of topics that you don't know anything Remember when we
talked about Heidegger last time and we agreed that shouting
is a silly thing to do. Remember when we talked about that? Can
you name one of Heidegger's books? I can't. See, this is this
is a like she should be able to flip this on him and but now
because she's lied about having read the books or she's at least
misremembering or misspeaking, however you want to put it, now
it looks like he has a good point, right? So she's feeling like
she has to retract. If she hadn't If she just not mentioned reading
books, she could just go, "Yeah, engage with the ideas." I don't
memorize titles Cuz you never read any of this. That's why. That's
true. You're a liar. I'm sorry, but Because you're lying and
you got busted lying. The issue was Name Name one Heidegger book.
Careful, I'll call you out again. Name one Heidegger book. I'm
joking. Come on. Name one Heidegger Jay, this is fallacious and
you know it. Please name one Heidegger book to show that you
have read Heidegger. I don't need to. Because you haven't. Have
you read him? Memorizing books Erudite is starting on Brian in
this episode as well. I don't know what's going on. She keeps
threatening him or something. It's really weird. Like every time
he like makes a comment that like backs up the other guy, she's
like she'll say, "I'll call I'll call you out for that stuff
yesterday. I'll call you out for that stuff yes It's like weird
this I was like, "What the Memorizing books is not evidence of
knowing a book. Have you read it? Can you define absolutism versus
objectivism? Have you read it? You said yesterday that they were
synonymous. Why did you Yes, I have read Heidegger. Name one
book. I can't. I've already told you I don't memorize titles.
No. Can you name the difference between objectivism and absolutism?
Cuz yesterday you said that they were synonymous.
Being in time is a Heidegger Again, this guy could own way harder
right now if he just started asking about concepts. What's your
favorite concept from Heidegger? What did you learn from Heidegger
that you really like that you took away? Right? And then extend
beyond that. That's how you like actually own here is it because
there is a chance that she is like totally Listen, there is some
there is some head trauma there. Maybe it's just, you know, proper
nouns are up, okay? Maybe she actually has the concepts entirely,
okay? It's possible. So just start discussing the concepts. the
proper nouns can just get kicked out, correct? Last time you
said that objectivism and absolutism is synonymous, which is
false and you know that that's false. Can you define the difference
between these two words? same thing You were not using them in
an equivocating way. Don't even equivocation, you idiot. Don't
you dare try it. Don't you dare. Give it a try. Can you name
one philosophy book? What's the difference Name one. I already
gave you I Just one. The one she didn't read. Plato's Republic.
Plato's Republic. Just one that you read. I've read parts of
Thus Spoke Zarathustra. And you couldn't Five Dialogues is also
a name of a book. Just because I don't know the specific letter
names doesn't mean that I haven't read the Five Dialogues. I
can walk you through walk you through multiple dialogues. The
first dialogue is broadly about arete, which is this idea of
like purpose of things. So he goes into lions and how their purpose
is is to like and how forks the purpose is to help you eat. Okay,
I mean that's better from Erudite. That looks better. All right.
dialogue is essentially, what is the purpose of humans? Because
they're somewhere between demons and God. So what is their purpose?
Because they're certainly not to be happy. That's the first one.
The fifth one, for example, goes into friendship. And friendship's
a virtue. And he talks about the three types of friendship. And
he asks the question, "How do you achieve Uh So this looks way
better for her, by the way. That that is like what she should
have been doing from the beginning. friendship's a virtue and
what are their values? This is why men uh Just so it's clear,
all of this proves that I've read these books. He's just mad
because I don't know the title of the dialogue. I'm sorry if
Doesn't prove that you read the book, but it proves that you
have some understanding of concepts of the book and might be
able to discuss them. So it's way better than you just saying
you read it. I'm able to say you large portions of what the book
is about. This proves that I have engaged with the philosophy.
You are so hard because you realize that you don't know the difference
between these two words, which massively calls into question
your validity. You have not even once answered the question of
the difference between absolutism and objectivism. Not once have
you answered it. What you don't understand is that those are
words that can be used in different systems that based on the
intentionality
and moral absolutism are defined very clearly because you said
just the words and those words depend on the systems that they're
used in and the philosophers that use them. No, you You said
that they were synonymous. This is what you do throughout debates
when you ask people to explain and they start to explain and
you just go because in your mind that's actually an argument.
Did you hear what he said though? This is like the unironic Darvo
thing. You do what I do. You have a vice. You said
Did you hear what he said? What's that? Where did you pick up
Darvo from? Where did you get that phrase from? Ha. Ha. What's
the difference? What's the difference, Jay? What? What's the
difference between absolutism and objectivism? I don't know why
you're running from this question so much. It's fine. It's easy
to ask this question and I can answer it based on the philosophers
that are in question. So, we can talk about Rand and objectivism
and we can talk about it. He's telling you that the words themselves
depend on the context and the there is Who owns the word? Who
agreed on a definition of objectivism? Oh, who agreed on it?
Broadly, the philosophical body of academic scholars.
There are schools of objectivism, schools You can search these
things and they come up in You just made the point. There are
schools of them. You made my point. Thank you. the point. That's
not your point. what he just told you. I'm telling you my point,
you idiot. No, you're not. made my point. You're so dumb. by
obfuscating. Look, look, I You made my point. If I tell you about
objectivism, I actually have to go back 30 years to Ayn Rand
objectivism, which actually isn't in the school of You just You
just proved his point. You proved my point, you idiot. No, I
did not. You just literally said what his point was. Literally,
you mouthed it. You mouthed his point. What do you mean no? I'm
telling you you did. What's the with what you said, dummy. So,
you agree that there's a difference between absolutism and objectivism,
that they are not synonymous terms, and yesterday when you implied
that they were synonymous terms to get a sick dunk on me, you
were lying. Or [__] I guess. same thing yesterday.
That the words are used by different philosophers in different
systems and it depends upon which one. So, you just won't say.
So, I I said earlier that I could say that I'm individually Mhm.
a subjectivist. Oh, I know you guys can keep I don't know why
you guys have to keep linking the Erudite Thirst Post TikTok.
I I get it. I get I get it. Okay, that is it for us today, guys.
Okay, we've watched a reasonable amount of this. I don't know.
I This actually is better than what I thought it would be. I
thought it would be like feminism debates, like a lot of feminism
red pill
So, this is better. This might be